enough is enough is enough and i believe
that's what a majority of this country
has been saying
has been screaming for a long time now
enough is enough what a crazy
sad day a day that will go down
as a dark one in the in the long history
of america there are some dark subjects
that we talk about on the show
occasionally
but i've rarely been as upset as i am
tonight
this was one of those days that i always
assumed was behind us this is not the
sort of thing that i
ever imagined would happen in this
country in my lifetime
we can be shocked but we can't be
surprised the president wanted this
he directed it supported it he incited
it
and encouraged it tv's late night hosts
weigh
in after violent riots break out at the
u.s
capitol it has been an extraordinary day
congressional leaders have pleaded for
president trump to call
off the protesters on wednesday a large
gathering of pro-trump supporters
breached capital security and entered
the building
forcing lawmakers into hiding while the
joint session of congress to ratify joe
biden's election win
was temporarily suspended later that
evening
late night hosts jimmy kimmel james
corden jimmy fallon
stephen colbert and seth meyers all made
special remarks
addressing the shocking events in their
opening monologues
calling out president donald trump for
inciting violence
and condemning the action of the rioters
this is what happens when there is no
peaceful transition of power
and what happens when there is bad
leadership this is not how you lose
if my grandfather were alive today and
saw what was happening in the country
that he fought for
he'd be disgusted people walking around
with the
flag upside down thinking they're
patriotic
today was not patriotism today was
terrorism jimmy fallon opened up the
tonight show
assuring his viewers that will be okay
and that the actions of the day
do not reflect what america is all about
today was a disgrace today was
disappointing
but sadly today was not a surprise
but it's important to remember that this
is not who we are i assure you
there are more good people than there
are bad and good will prevail
james corden opened up on the late late
show about growing up in
england and how he used to look to
america as a beacon of light and
possibility
today people across the world would have
looked at these pictures
from washington and they would have
wondered what on earth has happened to
this
great country but i truly believe and
make no mistake that they know that
the america that they admire still
exists they know
that the america that so many aspire to
will be back it's just been hijacked by
a lunatic
and his crazy army for the last four
years
but that's about to end and he
encouraged his viewers to stay hopeful
in two weeks on those same steps where
that mob fought and pushed past the
police
the people who encouraged and instigated
that violence
donald trump his children rudy giuliani
they're all going to need a tourist pass
to get in
because they've lost the presidency
they've lost the house
and now they've lost the senate today
was their last dance at the worst party
any of us
have ever been to so if you can have
hope i really do believe
that there are better times ahead and
while corden ended his message
on a positive note stephen colbert
kicked off the late show
telling his fans he's rarely been as
upset as he was on wednesday
republicans who supported this president
especially the ones in the joint session
of congress today
have you had enough after five years of
coddling this
president's fascist rhetoric guess whose
followers want to burn down the
reichstag
because today the u.s capitol was
overrun for the first time since 1814
and a woman
died who could have seen this coming
everyone even dummies like me
this is the most shocking most tragic
least
surprising thing i've ever seen jimmy
kimmel also took aim at donald trump for
encouraging his followers to hit up the
capital earlier in the day
at a rally he held where he claimed the
2020 presidential election had been
stolen
and that he was the rightful winner
despite no evidence to substantiate his
repeated
baseless claims the president of the
united states
because he is too angry too insecure
and too incompetent to deal with the
fact that he lost an election a fair
election
an election that was no different than
any other election an election he lost
by
7 million votes and 70 electors turns an
angry mob
against members of congress and his own
vice president
not to mention endangering the capitol
police those blue lives he claims matter
so much to him and kimmel he didn't stop
there
and the wildest part is these mega
marchers
think donald trump cares about them he
doesn't care about you
he doesn't care about your life or your
wife or your job or
your healthcare or the air you breathe
or the water you're drinking
cares about himself and only about
himself
unless you were pushing a lawnmower he
wouldn't let you into his golf club
he'd roll his limo right over you to get
a chick-fil-a sandwich
as for seth meyers he put all jokes
aside for the night on his show
late night pluralistic democracy
is fragile and precious and it requires
our vigilant stewardship and protection
and anyone
not willing to forward that project with
the fullness
of their effort must be shamed and
disgraced
and removed from office and that must
start
immediately with donald trump
we are going to try our best tonight to
process what happened
i promise i promise if you come back
tomorrow
we will have jokes